Going to be late.
-All right, I look good?
-Yes.
Water?
That came fromyour
thigh gap? No, thank you.
Thanks for calling it a gap.
We are catching up
with celebrity chef Sasha Tran
and her fiancé, Brandon Choi.
What a great cause, huh?
You're opening
a new restaurant
and I need you
in San Francisco.
Hey.
Hi, Marcus.
Yeah. Hi, Sasha. Hi. Hello. Hi.
Long time.
Yes, a very long time.
What's up?
-Sasha Tran!
-Mr. Kim!
You're likeour own
Asian Oprah.
How much money
do you have now?
He's serious.
Oh.
I'm surprisedyou two
lost touch.
You used to be so close.
So, when's
the big wedding day?
He wants to travel a bit
before we settle down.
It's really for the both of us.
I finally realized that
I don't want to get married.
Are you kidding me?
You're a piece of shit!
I can tell you're a little--
I hope you get malaria
and shit yourself to death,
you shitty piece of shit!
A little softer, please.
You are scaring the goats.
I guess I have to start
dating again.
Is there anything worse?
You and Marcus are so cute.
Nope.
Remind me why
you never got together?
There's way too much
history there.
Yeah.
You still have the Corolla?
What are you looking at?
My back seat?
Because we had sex
back there?
Oh, my God.
So, what do you think?
That it might be even smaller
and grosser than I remember.
Hey, you better still be
talking about my back seat.
You don't want to wonder
"what if?"
Tell her how you feel, son.
I have some news.
-So do I.
-Mine's big.
Mine's big, too.
Okay, look...
Okay, I want to go first!
I met someone!
Wow. That's so great.
We had the most insane,
freaky-ass sex.
I can't even talk about it--
Yeah, let's stop
talking about it.
Oh, there he is!
Oh...
my...
God.
Hi, baby.
I miss your flesh.
I miss your thighs.
I miss your beard
scratching my thighs.
I missed your taste.
I missed your thumbs.
You're so good
with your thumbs.